[Music]
all the Riverdale fans love that your
on-screen kids have formed an off-screen
bond Lily just posted the sweetest
message to Kol for his birthday
yeah how sweet is that for you guys to
see this relationship evolve it's great
I mean they didn't talk about it you
know the entire time until just recently
so it's it's nice that they're able to
now like be public with it so that if
it's not so under wraps but at the same
time they're in complete control of what
they want to share and how they want to
share it but behind the scenes they're
so sweet with each other and they're
both just exceptional people so yeah I'm
really glad they have each other it's
like it's it's a lot it's a lot of work
it's a long season it's nice they really
keep each other grounded and supported
and their friendship is beautiful Betty
and jugheads on-screen parents giving
their stamp of approval to Lily Reinhart
and Cole Sprouse is off screen romance
with et at the summer tcas
where they also shared a small season
three teas what can we expect from
season three an epidemic yeah of pure
evil it's even darker than the previous
two seasons and there's there's already
so many twists I know we're only on
Episode three yeah and it's already
throwing us for a loop we're like okay
yeah here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]